foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the Hall of Famer former NFL head coach
the Colts and the Buccaneers and of
course football night in America
contributor and a Detroit Lions fan tone
you have reason to root for the Lions
this year are you on the bandwagon
finally a little hope Dan uh I I see
some defense starting to come around the
offense was playing great early in the
year but I was wondering if we could
stop anybody Aaron Glenn's got that unit
plan better and better Aiden Hutchinson
making some big plays so I think there
is a little room for Hope okay you said
we
if yeah
if the Lions played the Colts
oh that's a tough one that's a tough one
I'm probably rooting for the Colts
because I I worked for them and I I have
people they paid my patients never paid
my paycheck the Lions well weren't you
up for the Lions job or did you consider
coaching the Lions years ago
Martin Mayhew was uh doing a coaching
search he was the GM Mart had played for
me in Tampa and he's asked me about Jim
Caldwell and he said before we get
started I I have to ask the obligatory
question and because of my roots and
growing up there my dad being such a
lions fan I actually told Martin I would
think about it for 24 hours uh before I
said no but I thought about it for 24
hours and said no but this is where you
talk to your wife and
you have to bring no it it really didn't
even go there oh okay I I told Martin if
my dad was still alive I I probably
would have done it because of his love
for the Lions and all my roots but uh at
that point I was I was done coaching all
right help me understand this with
roughing the passer the number of
roughing the passer calls are down
significantly 37 but anger is up because
we're not quite sure if you're a
defensive player
how do you sack somebody now and and we
never thought that we would get to this
point how did we get to this point
we got to this point because we want to
protect the quarterbacks and the
investment in the game and we all
understand that and so you're trying to
create rules and trying to create a
black and white where it can't be black
and white it's got to be one of those
things where you know it when you see it
um I I remember
when they first put in the rule if you
hit the quarterback in the head it's
rough in the past
and so we had a couple guys trying to
block passes and they just touched the
head
and we got penalties so John turlink was
our defensive line coach he comes in to
me says we are never trying to block
another pass we're going right at the
midsection we're laying out we're taking
one step we're hitting these guys right
in the midsection and then people get
upset about that because oh you hit them
with your full body weight so now it's
we you know you can't try to block a
pass you can't hit him in the knee you
can't put their whole body weight you
know when somebody is drilling the
quarterback and taking an extra shot
that's what the officials should call
when the the
uh linebacker from Miami you know has
both hands in there and barely touches
the guy you can't call that rough in the
past you just can't and that's what
people are angry about but I'm how about
if we have it where it's reviewable but
do you have only a certain number no you
don't like that no reviews don't work we
saw that with past interference and
we're sitting there and they're
reviewing it and you're saying as Mike
homerun would say 50 drunks in a bar
would say this is not passing appearance
and they would say the call stands so
you know it's just I don't think reviews
are the key I think it's just educating
these officials you know what rough in
the past is when a guy is taking an
extra shot when he's taken two steps
when he pushed them down unnecessarily
when he really does drive him into the
church not just fall on him but drive
him into the turf we know what rough in
the past there is just just call it but
did you ever feel like an official even
though he knew he was wrong was not
going to change it because ego gets
involved well and that's where part of
our problem is if we would come on
Monday at these NFL press conferences
and say you know what that that call in
in the charges again it wasn't rough in
the past so we made a mistake everybody
could live with that because every
everybody does make mistakes but when
you say no Calvin Johnson really didn't
catch the ball and then you know
everybody and their mother says no he
caught it he took two steps he put his
hands down on the ground he got him to
celebrate and he dropped the ball that
was a touchdown Detroit should have won
the game
but when you say well no it really
wasn't a catch and then you start having
to make rules because you want to
justify that and then the next catch you
you know so that's what happens and
we're getting that with roughing the
passers we're getting that with taking
the helmet off you know
the the Saints move are not the Saints
but the the Panthers lose a game because
a guy's celebrating in the stands with
the fans and we throw a flag and just
instead of saying we were wrong that we
don't want that call we try to justify
it now when the next guy takes his
helmet off we don't call it we do call
it that that's where people get upset
talking to Tony Dungy the Hall of Famer
scoring is down the games are closer but
scoring is down and I I want to give
credit to the defense you know the
Niners have a great defense Dallas has
you know a formidable defense
um and I don't know if it's philosophy
Tony that and it felt like it started
with the Kansas City Chiefs we're going
to make you Dink and dunk and not let
you beat us with a big play and I don't
know if other teams are kind of
subscribing to that
people are adopting that they are um you
know trying to take away the big play
they're drafting Defenders I I never
thought we'd see cornerbacks drafted in
the top four but sauce Gardner you know
is is a factor and people are saying I
want that so there is an emphasis on
defense but Dan I think that really the
big thing is lack of practice time and
lack of working together I I just think
we've cut down on practices we've cut
down on what you can do and this this
hurts the offenses
well I also go back to Green Bay when
Aaron Rodgers was upset with those young
receivers I was upset with Aaron Rodgers
being upset with them because he already
knows how to play the game they don't
and I thought that that was a real
missed opportunity for Green Bay that he
would be with those young receivers you
you are so right my last year coach in
2008
um we draft Anthony Gonzalez number one
from Ohio State wide receiver he can't
come because Ohio state has the long you
know they're in school in May and until
June Peyton Manning at that point had
already won a Super Bowl he'd won three
MVPs Peyton Manning got in his car twice
a week drove from Indianapolis to
Columbus Ohio took the Playbook with him
went over the playbook for an hour with
Anthony Gonzalez threw routes at their
facility for an hour and drove back
eight hours a day on his own we never
asked him to do that twice a week on his
own to help Anthony Gonzalez get ready
so when Aaron Rodgers says oh we've got
these young receivers and they aren't
ready but oh by the way I wasn't there
during the summer you you can't I I
don't buy that the NBA came out with
Awards and they named him after players
the MVP award is Michael Jordan uh even
though Kareem has one more MVP than Mike
does but I was wondering if we did this
with the NFL
how do you think Peyton would take this
if I said the regular season MVP is the
Peyton Manning award the Super Bowl MVP
is the Tom Brady award
I think that would make sense uh you
look at how many MVPs Peyton has won you
look at how many you know MVPs the Super
Bowls Brady has won
um I think that would make sense I do
think we have a recency bias when we
talk that way you might want to go back
to the Otto Graham award or the Jim
Brown award or the Sammy ball award we
don't realize how great some of those
guys were but uh I could see what you're
saying I could go with that yeah I I but
I love that we we don't forget those who
played before because there is the
recency bias people don't remember
Johnny Unitas
um and and what he meant to that
position like he was the first modern
day quarterback with what he did the
two-minute drill I mean and we we forget
Peyton modeled his game after United and
he was a throwback to that that era uh I
can remember my dad the first game I
ever went to in Detroit my dad took me
to a lions Browns preseason game because
he wanted me to see Jim Brown and it
just that was my dad's era and he wanted
me to know that was greatness
well I try to tell people about Jim
Brown and oh
do you I I still don't know how to
describe what he did how he did it when
he did it and that he got so bored that
he went into acting he he just said is
there any other challenges here nope I'm
gonna be an actor here after nine
seasons
my coach Chuck Knoll I was a man of few
words but I I rarely saw him speechless
he blocked for Jim Brown when I asked
him about Jim Brown he just he couldn't
even describe it he said he was so far
ahead of his time and so skilled and so
good
um he you know he didn't want to
downplay his own role but he really
didn't need blockers I didn't know Chuck
Knoll block for Jim Brown he was the
alternating uh guard messenger guard for
Paul Brown yes yep uh what are the
Cowboys getting with T.Y Hilton
I I think they're getting a guy who can
be explosive and can make some plays
they've got a great receiving core
cd-lam is going to get all the attention
and they've got gallop and and they've
got tight ends so now when you bring Ty
Hilton in as the third receiver maybe
the fourth receiver in a four wide
receiver said well he's going to get
single covered and this is still a guy
who has speed and quickness and can beat
single coverage and and I would see him
doing some damage here down the strip
but it feels like Jerry Jones has had
his eye on obj
and somehow someway he's going to bring
him in I don't know when he can play but
it feels like Jerry Jones is committed
to obj
I I think they're going to get obj my
guess is it will probably be next year
because if you're going to get him this
year and he was going to do something
for you in the playoffs I don't think he
would assigned T.Y Hill you don't need
that with all the other receivers you
have
um I I think Jerry is infatuated with
big names he saw what obj did down the
stretch for the ram I don't know if
Odell is ready to go and he can play at
that level yet I don't think anybody
knows but I think Jerry Jones would like
to see that I don't think it's going to
happen this year we might have snow in
Buffalo with the Dolphins and the
Buffalo Bills now you coached in
Indianapolis and you coached in Tampa so
you weren't around the elements unless
you went on the road what was your
philosophy in telling your players well
certainly in Tampa when you'd be on the
road and cold weather
what did you say
well Indianapolis we could deal with it
because we just would practice Outdoors
we're playing on the road this week in
Buffalo we're going to practice Outdoors
we've got the same elements and we'd get
ready for it in Tampa there's no way you
can get ready for it so you have to take
the I took the Bud Grant approach and
Mike McDaniel is trying to do that you
know it's mental but Grant used to say
that heat was physical cold is mental
and that's the way it no and it's true
it's true and uh he would tell a story
every year when the weather would turn
cold about working on the Alaskan
Pipeline when he was a student at the
University of Minnesota and they had an
Eskimo who was fixing the tractors and
the guys who came up from Minnesota
could only be out there 15 minute shifts
and then it was too cold well the
tractor broke the Eskimo came and fixed
and he's out there an hour and a half
right yeah I think I got it ready and
they're like how can you be out there an
hour and a half you can only be out
there 15 minutes he said I'm not trying
to stay warm I'm trying to fix the
tractor you're staying warm so as soon
as you get cold you come in
and so Bud said we're trying to fix the
track we're not trying to stay warm and
he would get the guys like Sammy white
from Grambling and Rashad and they'd go
out there with no gloves and no sleeves
and play and we're not trying to stay
warm so uh it is a little bit mental but
when you you can't practice in it you
can't walk around in it uh it's a shock
to your system when you go out there on
that field we're just fine trying to fix
the tractor
um I'll leave you with this are the
Niners good enough defensively to go to
the Super Bowl just with that defense
they are uh that defense is very good
they can run the football Brock Purdy is
surprised me the last two weeks he's
throwing the ball well but even if he
doesn't if he is just okay or slightly
below average the way they can run and
the way they can play defense John Lynch
was on the the Super Bowl team in Tampa
John Lynch was on our 99 team that went
right to the championship game with that
formula of playing defensive running the
ball and I know that's what they've sold
and I believe they can do it I believe
they can do it always great to talk to
you my best to uh Lauren and the kids
over the holidays thank you buddy thank
you DP always great to be on with you
yeah it's the Hall of Famer Tony Dungy
we're just trying to fix the tractor
Paulie that's all we're doing you